what is up everybody it's annamac here
for anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the very latest events in
the boku no hero story including the
crazy reveal that there are more traders
inside the ua we also have izawa's
high-risk gamble and the beginning of
the second war arc in the mha manga this
is another major watershed moment in the
series so let's get into it you guys
know the drill if you enjoy our videos
and you want to see more please leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps a ton with the
youtube algorithm and of course if you
haven't subscribed already don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications
actually let me know down in the
comments real quick are you subscribed
how long have you been subscribed and if
you're not subscribed how long have you
been watching the channel and why didn't
you subscribe yet finally this video
will of course contain boku do hero
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned so in the
previous chapter we got that massive
reveal that toga now has the ability to
use sad man's parade which in my opinion
tilted the scales in favor of the
villains for the upcoming final battle
dead man's parade is already the quirk
equivalent of a nuclear weapon but with
someone as disturbed and unpredictable
as toga in the driver's seat dead man's
parade could become a major threat not
just to the ua but to all of japan and
if that wasn't enough to show us that
the villains have the advantage this
latest chapter reveals that there are
more traders already embedded inside the
ua grounds aoyama and his parents were
just the beginning now if you guys have
been following my videos for a while
then you already know that i've been
predicting this exact revelation for a
long time i've been saying that with all
those civilians now taking refuge inside
the ua there was always a high
likelihood that some of them would be
agents sent by all for one to pose as
civilians in order to gain access to the
ua then from inside the ua grounds they
can keep an eye on which heroes are
going in and out of the school and they
can also keep an eye on the security
system and security measures that have
been put in place infiltrating the ua
will undoubtedly be a challenge for the
villains especially with that new
state-of-the-art security system but
with agents on the inside who could
potentially open a metaphorical back
door to let the villains in the prospect
of the villain's infiltrating the ua
becomes a lot more likely and with
everybody focusing on the fact that
aoyama was finally exposed as the ua
trader most fans haven't been thinking
all that much about other potential
traders but in this latest chapter we
learned that there are at least two
other traders inside the ua at this
point in time one is a woman who wears a
beanie and the other is mob from mob
cycle 100. mob tells this woman
discreetly that they've received
instructions from all for one their job
is to try and stir up all the civilians
within the ua shelter who still harbor
animosity towards the heroes the heroes
know that shigaraki will be ready to
fight in less than a week and they also
know that they are extremely
short-handed and overstretched so far
they've been keeping these facts on the
down low so as not to cause panic but
the traders need to fan the flames by
emphasizing these inconvenient truths to
all the civilians inside the shelter who
are willing to listen all for one spies
want to scare the civilians into
thinking that a huge villain attack
could happen at any moment and that the
main target of this attack will be deku
all for one wants the civilians to rise
up against the heroes and force deku to
leave the ua grounds yet again once deku
is forced to leave it will be much
easier for over one to get him and steal
one for all meanwhile inside the class
1a dormitories we see that all the
students have been working extremely
hard they've been searching for the
villains with an emphasis on dobby while
also trying to make all possible
preparations for the inevitable final
showdown against the villains poor
minata doesn't even have time to talk
about pervy things anymore and that is
just sad you guys sad all might
tsukauchi and nezu then show up to
reveal the top secret details of izaba's
master plan for the second war against
the villains and the fact that they are
referring to this as the second war
tells me that this final battle is going
to be just as epic and just as
consequential as the battle of jakku so
strap yourselves in everybody because
it's about to go down very soon all
might stresses that only a small number
of people are going to know about the
plan and unfortunately we the manga
readers are not part of that small
number at least not yet but we do know
that the main players in the plan appear
to be the class 1a students including
aoyama hawks genius endeavor and ragdoll
as well as aizawa and kurogiri the fact
kurogiri is shown at this point is very
significant we've always known that his
true identity as oboroshirakumo meant
that he would become relevant to the
story once again and of course his quirk
makes him an incredibly valuable asset
for the heroes if they can somehow
figure out a way to override his
programming i am very curious to see
what isawa has planned for kurogiri
especially since we know that izawa has
such a personal connection to obaro what
do you guys think the heroes are
planning to do with kurogiri will they
be able to override his programming and
turn him back into obero will they be
able to use warpgate to their advantage
will they try to use kurogiri as bait to
lure out some of the villains definitely
share your thoughts down in the comments
below now the next day the heroes end up
doing something that shocks everyone
including the traitors within the ua
they outright reveal to everyone
publicly that shigaraki will be able to
fight again in about four days and that
he may attack the ua at that time they
then also publicly announced that deku
and class 1a are leaving the ua grounds
which is exactly what the villains
wanted we can't forget that the traders
were specifically instructed to scare
the civilians at ua with the prospect of
shigaraki attacking at any moment and
then they were to use that fear to
pressure deku to leave the safety of the
ua but now the heroes have apparently
done the traitor's work for them they
informed everyone about the imminent
threat and then they willingly took deco
in class 1a outside of ua the traders
can't believe their incredible luck but
of course we have to assume that this is
all part of iso's plan and that things
won't go as smoothly for the villains as
they would like to think we then see
some emotional scenes of class 1a
students saying goodbye to their friends
and family deku hugs his mom and says
goodbye shoto bids farewell to his
mother and siblings bakugo's hot mom
nags him about something kota neri say
goodbye to deku and so on the students
are moved some 30 kilometers away from
ua into a fortified building called
prototype stronghold troy this building
was specifically designed to take a
beating and to keep the people inside
safe and although they are not as safe
as at the ua it will get the job done i
just hope the students know they can't
do any horsing around you know because
the building's name is troy yes yes it
was a great joke and i'm sure my editor
axel beats won't do anything to take
away from the greatness of that joke i
don't really have to do anything to make
that joke any worse than it already was
honestly it just hurt
and you could probably start calling me
achilles because i don't think i'm ever
gonna heal
by the way shout out to my editor axel
beats a lot of you guys commented in the
last video that you loved his little
toga edit so yeah axel take a bow being
into completely deranged yandere girls
is definitely not a cry for help anyway
once the students are settled into the
new facility deku sees ochako standing
outside on her own so he decides to join
her deku then finally properly thanks
ochako for standing up for him so
publicly back at ua and ochako is all
like blushy and shy about it and she
says oh i didn't do anything much
just get married already you two the
conversation eventually moves to quote
unquote best girl himiko toga the
conversation eventually moves to best
girl himiko toga ochako reveals that she
saw an image of toga's face flashed in
her mind while she was giving her pro
deku speech back at ua and she remembers
that the last time she saw toga back in
jakku she had made the saddest
expression that ochako had ever seen
this happened after ochako implied that
with toga being the way that she is the
two of them could never be friends since
toga believes that she is only now being
her true self after being pressured to
be someone else for her entire childhood
toga took ochako's words as confirmation
that they will never be able to see eye
to eye despite the fact that toga wants
to be friends with ochoko they have
completely different world views and
those two world views are inherently
incompatible as a result they can never
be friends only enemies and while ochako
still feels that way she firmly believes
that the actions of the league of
villains are irredeemable she still
feels bad about toga clearly there is
some humanity within toga there is some
genuine human compassion and emotion and
a desire for friendship and connection
but her way of life is so warped and so
incompatible with the life of a hero
that there is simply no way for a hero
to ever be friends with her ocheko and
deku are destined to end up facing toga
in a battle to the death and that day
will likely come sooner rather than
later ochoko thinks that her mixed
feelings about toga make her weird but
deku says that he understands he also
has mixed feelings about shigaraki
because for a brief moment he caught a
glimpse of a crying little boy tenko
shimura deep inside the villain who is
known today as tomorrow shigaraki so
again there is a major conflict there
between a hero's desire to save whatever
goodness is left inside these villains
and a hero's duty to stop them from
causing more harm and destruction but no
matter what happens deku and ochako vow
to stop the villains as i've said many
times before deku's believed that he
could still maybe possibly save tenko
shimura could come back to haunt him big
time i am seriously concerned that
during the final battle shigaraki will
trick deku into lowering his guard
because he wants to save tenko shigaraki
will then take advantage of that moment
to attack deku and i could totally see
all might sacrificing his own life in
order to protect deku from that attack i
could be wrong of course but i feel like
this exact thing will happen during the
final battle if i'm wrong then forget i
ever said this but if i'm right feel
free to praise me as the anime prophet
the chapter ends with all for one
declaring that the villain operation
begins today right now and the text on
the final page tells us that the second
war is already ramping up
whoa all of this talk about a second war
and second war arc is really emphasizing
just how massive this next arc is going
to be the second war will likely decide
the outcome of the entire story major
deaths may occur and things will never
be the same again i am both scared and
excited to see what happens next on the
one hand i can't wait to see the final
battle but on the other i am worried
that we're gonna lose some major
characters and knowing horikoshi some of
them could be waifus and that is just
not acceptable anyway let me know what
you guys think about this setup for the
second war what is aizawa's plan and why
would he play right into the villain's
hands by taking deku out of ua does his
plan include using warpgate to split the
villains off from each other and then
take them on one by one if so how will
he be able to reprogram kurogiri also
what is all for one's master plan at the
end of the chapter he clearly appears to
be setting up his own plans so what is
he about to do how is he going to use
those other traders at ua don't forget
to leave your thoughts down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more boku no hero
content right here on the channel leave
a quick like it only takes a second but
it helps a lot and if you're new to
anime uproar or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications subscribing
is a completely free but very important
way of directly supporting the channel
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror i want to give a
quick thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible special thank you to
alpha sigma and kyle salisbury these
guys are absolute mad lads and disciples
of lord twigo himself and i can't forget
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans including
ingrata algital pate heffa the
red-haired fox hinokamien water the
toasted chi corey mcgowan the spike
lonely the car dylan isadore spidey life
chanel tungsten tarkis big buddhist
jeremy cummings and che whitley finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers on hell cruise very
gucci alicia octor bonnie parks joanne
garcia fat boy games kaido might be a
duck jessica rabbit jeremy phillips
alivania temple king matthew and
demetrius water if you guys enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patreon exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
oh and if you don't have a patreon
account becoming a youtube channel
member gives you the same perks as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you